ils l'ont fait ils l'ont fait ils
offraient et ça c'est cool je vous le
disais l'année dernière ce pas si vous
vous souvenez dans ma vidéo je faisais
le test de la surface prosys je vous
disais trouve que c'est dommage que sur
une machine comme ça qui est quand même
une machine haut de gamme
on ne trouve pas de port usb c est là
justement eh bien regardez ils nous ont
mis de l'usbc qui est ici lac et planck
est juste là de l'usbc enfin enfin merci
microsoft d'avoir mis de l'usbc pour
rendre cette machine compatible avec
plein d'autres produits avec plein de
produits pouvaient maintenant brancher
directement piolenc produits il est
sympa il est vraiment bien cette surface
trop 7
elle y fera cool je vous emmener il ya
quelques jours avec moi à new york pour
la découvrir dans les palaces de new
york fait super beau choix qu'il fait
quelque chose de taxes comme 30 degrés
aujourd'hui on joue surface gros avec
elle à new york relation pas ce procès
moi je trouve ça vraiment cool est
maintenant l'heure est venue de vous
dire ce que j'en pense comment je
trouvais ce qu'elle est bien est ce
qu'elle est intéressante est ce qu'elle
est super quels sont les points positifs
de cette surface procède qu'elles sont
aussi ces points négatifs
est ce qu'elle est faite pour vous et au
final est-ce qu'il faut l'acheter oui
[Musique]
non non
c'est beau c'est beau c'est beau c'est
beau c'est beau c'est bon moi j'aime
beaucoup la gamme surface de microsoft
est d'autant plus qu'aujourd'hui on
parle de la surface pro 7 qui le
plancton et j'ai tellement de trucs je
suis toujours sous la surface pro7 avec
le signature pipe cover le mexique sud
le plus lu présente non je vous raconte
même pas l'histoire et dans quelques
jours on va se parler dans priori hypra
hypra ipred cool que j'attendais aussi
perdu moment c'est ça la surface pro x
celle là c'est un peu autre chose c'est
une surface promet une surface pro qui
se connectent de partout grâce à
qualcomm enfin ça je vous en reparle
dans quelques jours j'ai aussi ça il ya
le style avec à la complète c'est
vraiment génial et pour que je suis très
heureux de pouvoir vous en parler parce
que vous emmenez l'autre jour avec moi à
new york était très impatient de pouvoir
découvrir ses produits pouvoir vous sans
parler de dialogue pour faire un petit
peu un tour global touristique vous
allez voir il n'y a rien de bien
révolutionnaire de ce côté là il ya
quelques petites nouveautés vous allez
voir ok cool on va acheter un petit coup
d'oeil j'adore ce petit bout les uns
fait toujours rêver que j'adore c'est
magnifique ce plan commence tout de
suite et je compte rebondir en bas en
commentaire ce que vous en pensez pour
les mauvais élèves au fond de la classe
je vais rapidement vous représentez ce
qu'est la surface pro alors la surface
pro en fait c'est pas exactement ça la
surface pro c'est ça c'est une deux hors
norme ias mi chemin entre un ordinateur
et une tablette vous ne prenez comme ça
c'est effectivement une tablette une
très grande tablette avec un très grand
écran de 2,6 pouces me revient dessus
dans quelques instants
c'est aussi une petite tablette que vous
pouvez poser comme ça en eau de cheval
et puisque vous avez le petit cheval et
qui est extrêmement résistant on a
vraiment autour de sensation de
robustesse lorsque vous venez de poser
constamment à vraiment très très
rassurant et lorsque vous voulez
l'utiliser comme un ordinateur et bien
il faut acheter à part et ça c'est
toujours un peu point de regrets mais
bon ça permet à chacun de choisir ce
qu'il veut et de mettre l'argent là où
il veut son fort sans doute avoir un
produit qui va être beaucoup trop cher
vous avez le sofa starting over vous
prenez vous branchez vous tac vous le
montrer comme ça et là ça vous fait une
belle machine ça vous fait un bel
ordinateur vrai 2 en homme que vous
venez ensuite replié vous emmener
partout avec vous derrière il ya la
dénomination pro parce que c'est une
machine performance une machine
puissante nous permettra de faire
beaucoup de choses que vous soyez
créatif où ils créative que vous
souhaitiez dessinée avec un stylet style
et que j'ai pas donc je peux pas vous
faire les démonstrations aujourd'hui de
style et c'est un peu dommage parce que
j'aurais voulu faire deux trois trucs
notamment liées à office avec le stylet
malheureusement dans
exemplaire de près on m'envoyait la
surface et m'envoyer le clavier tibco
voir mais en a pas sur les petits bois
toujours elle n'a pas envoyé de style et
donc je peux pas vous faire les démos là
on en reprendrait un des sites quelques
jours sur la surface pro x parce que
pour le coup il ya un style etc est
magnifique le stylet qui est intégré
directement dans le clavier comme ça ça
permettra de voir tout ça directement
ensemble vous invite à vous abonner si
ce n'est pas déjà le cas pour tout
savoir sur cette surface pro x d'ici
quelques jours et croyez moi ça va être
vraiment très intéressant surface prodon
qui est là pour le professionnel qui est
magique et très performante nachi et
endurante une machine qui est
extrêmement polyvalente que ce soit pour
du contenu multimédia
netflix ce que vous voulez tout seul
pour dessiner soit pour travailler que
ce soit pour faire un petit peu
d'infographie c'est l'adn de cette
bécane elle est bien elle est robuste
elle est compacte coupure c'est une
vidéo qui a réalisé en partenariat avec
zen make vpn pour parler de votre
sécurité en ligne protéger vos données
protéger votre anonymat
question votre sécurité en ligne la
question de l'anonymat lorsque vous
allez surfer sur internet c'est quand
même très très important et souvent on
néglige et on a tort à quoi va vous
servir en dp et bien des peines à vous
servir à vous protéger à être annoni par
exemple vous allez dans un hôtel vous
allez utiliser le wifi d'un hôtel le
wifi public le wifi d'un mcdo le wifi
d'un aéroport n'importe lequel dès lors
vous avez en wifi public quelqu'un qui
s'y connaît le pouvoir intercepter des
données va pouvoir récupérer des données
sur vous et ça s'est relativement btan
donc est ce que fait des peines
il va venir créer un tunnel sécurisé
entre votre ordinateur et lui il à venir
en crypté vos données et personne ne
pourra les bords et personne ne pourra y
avoir accès ça vous permet de vous
protéger et préserver votre anonymat et
surtout toutes les données qui vont
transiter par internet
autre cas usa ce qui est intéressant
vous voulez réserver sur internet je
sais pas moi un avion vous voulez
réserver un hôtel vous savez qu'à m'en
veux un peu traqué par des cookies et
comme par hasard à jaffa vous revenez le
prix augmenter vous utilisez un vpn vous
anonymisées et bien vous allez voir les
prix d'un coup ne vont pas augmenter
pour des paiements en ligne typiquement
personne doit pouvoir capter vos données
d'une manière générale avait-elle fou et
ça vient vous anonymisées ça vient vous
sécurisez ça revient vous protégez vous
et vos données et croyez moi ça c'est
extrêmement important et elle m'aide vpn
existe depuis 2013 à protéger puis 47
millions de personnes et disponibles
évidemment sur mac ici sur windows vous
l'avez aussi sur ios sur android il ya
plus
848 charmeur 10 passes et dans plus de
35 pays par monde entier avec un seul et
même abonnement pour l'utiliser sur cinq
appareils différents et si vous n'êtes
pas satisfait dans les 30 jours vous
serez remboursé par zenit points forts 2
mbps et king a absolument aucune donnée
sur vous il n'ya pas de log l'encryptage
est de qualité militaire il ya plein de
saveurs dans le monde entier nous quel
que soit le lieu où vous allez vous
connectez vous allez pouvoir vous
connecter à votre vpn très facilement et
profiter de la meilleure connexion sans
aucun ralentissement
c'est rapide c'est pratique ça vous
protège c'est sécurisé c'est anonymisées
il n'y a que des avantages à voir vais
pas dit en plus sage à tarif intéressant
pour vous une promo pour vie de la part
des notes dpn quel est le lien badar
description vous avez confié le 4e 22 %
de remise savent où sort un tarif à 1
euros 75 par mois soit 21 euros par an
pour venir vous protégez vous
anonymisées et croyez moi c'est très
important aujourd'hui si vous utilisez
souvent des wifi public pensez vraiment
vous protéger ça vous évitera quelques
déconvenues
je vais passer extrêmement rapidement
sur le produit vous avez soit une
version tablette soit une version pc là
on est sur la version tablette vous avez
aussi une version pc vous pouvez
switcher d'un mode à l'autre ou tac vous
venez là vous appuyez vous allez me
laisser vous faites ce que vous voulez
dans tous les cas vous avez un écran
tactile dans tous les cas vous avez un
écran pixel celle de 12,3 pouces 2736
par 1824 pixels à 267 pixels par pouce
des haut parleurs dolby atmos une prise
jack qui est situé juste ici vous avez
également du bluetooth 5.0 pour pouvoir
venir à péret un casque sans fil
vous avez donc une machine qui est
vraiment idéal pour le côté multimédia
que des divertissements que ce soit pour
regarder du contenu multimédia à des
séries un film tout ce que vous voulez
l'audio est vraiment vraiment que vous
avez vraiment une expérience est très
sympa et c'est pas tout parce que vous
avez également de la performance avec un
intel core de deuxième génération
i3/i5/i7 grave et andy llano m soit 4 8
ou 16 giga de ram soit 128 256 512 ou
carrément un terrain de stockage ou ce
point de vue là vous avez une machine
qui va être polyvalent qui va s'adapter
une fois de plus c'est vraiment toujours
son adn la polyvalence qui va s'adapter
à vos besoins
il faut vraiment réfléchir réfléchissez
vraiment lorsque vous venez acheter ce
type au logis de produits savoir quels
sont vos besoins aujourd'hui quels
seront vos besoins de demain
pensez vraiment en termes de ram pour
moi 4 gigas de ram vous pouvez être
rapidement limité sauf pour un côté un
peu multimédia mais je dirais qu'une
machine comme ça a lâché que pour le
multimédia ça serait quand même un petit
peu ballot cette machine là il va
appeler un petit peu de performance donc
il vous faut un peu de ram derrière donc
pour moi c'est giga de ram là dessus
c'est vraiment pas du luxe
pareil en termes de stockage 128 go ça
me paraît un petit peu bas 256 pourquoi
pas mais en tout cas un minimum je
dirais plutôt là dessus sur du 512 voire
carrément intéresse vous pouvez vous le
permettre alors bien évidemment ça
dépend dans une fois de plus de votre
portefeuille puisque 52 guigou tout
petit peu cher mais c'est aussi
relativement normal vu la qualité du
produit
il ya un autre point qui est intéressant
c'est la partie autonomie microsoft nous
annonce 10,5 heures d'autonomie alors
j'ai pas trouvé également 10,5 heures
d'autonomie c'est super non plus à l'est
avec le chronomètre mais je dirais que
un petit peu moins de dix heures vous
les avez peut-être entre 8h30 et 9h30 là
ça me semble assez cohérent et il faut
savoir vous rechargez très rapidement en
une heure de charge
vous l'avez monte à 80% donc si vous
avez oublié de charger et vous partez
dans une heure prendre le train vous
êtes donc en changer rapidement ça pour
moi c'est aussi un point positif
maintenant moyens truc que je vais
regretter là-dessus fondamentalement et
c'est dommage parce que je trouve que le
design il
alors le design il efficace il marche ca
dre qui a déjà été vue qui est revu
revue chez microsoft avec sa gamme
surface on change pas vraiment design je
trouve qu'on a des boks open un petit
peu trop épais aujourd'hui en 2019 fin
2019 bientôt début 2005 c'est dommage ça
aurait été bien qu'on les débords un
petit peu plus fin pour gagner peut-être
en dimensions alors pourquoi pas pour
réagir un petit peu l'écran à la demande
en tout cas ça me semblerait vraiment
bien alors effectivement vous avez toute
la partie de caméras sont stockées ici
pour windows et l'eau pour venir
déverrouiller très facilement pour la
sécurité qui a un sens c'est aussi de
pouvoir faire de la conférence via skype
pour pouvoir travailler puisque une fois
de plus seul dans un outil professionnel
ça se comprend mais j'aurais trouvé ça
bien et c'est possible aujourd'hui
technologiquement de réduire ici ce
petit espace c'est vraiment dommage on
reste sur un truc qui est quand même
très identique par rapport aux
générations précédentes il n'y a pas de
prise de risque là dessus néanmoins
c'est un produit qui marche mais
j'aurais aimé un petit peu plus de prise
de risque en tout cas venir rajeunir et
rafraîchir en tout cas ce design on l'a
tous fait exactement la même chose quand
les indiens l'année dernière j'avais dit
dans ma vidéo du test de la surface
grossistes microsoft il faudrait mettre
de l'usbc ça s'est fait sur l'a7 bravo
merci maintenance dans la surface
produite
il faudrait mettre de l'usbc thunderbolt
3 ça serait bien ça va dans le bon sens
on gagnerait significativement en
vitesse notamment pour tous les
vidéastes qui travaille avec un disque
dur externe napo coupe ça serait
merveilleux
donc j'espère microsoft qu'en 2020 eh
bien on aura la chance et le bonheur de
découvrir de l'usbc thunderball 3 sur la
surface pro 8 pour continuer un petit
peu la partie matérielle vous lisez vous
avez ici une caméra de 5 mégapixels
qu'elle avait encore envie de filmer en
1080p pour la partie conférence que vous
avez également une petite caméra qui est
situé ici à l'arrière avec le petit
micro caché ici 8 mégapixels qui vous
sert également à filmer en 1080p
bien évidemment là dessus on est sur un
windows dix familles pour windows 10 à
main je vous connaissez ça ça marche
très très bien
vous avez la possibilité d'avoir le pack
office qui vous servir pour tout le côté
productivité
il ya des petites améliorations qui ont
été faites sont apparus à la surface pro
x notamment au niveau d'excel et
notamment au niveau du world sur la
reconnaissance manuscrite lorsque vous
écrivez golf style et on peut acheter en
option en plus surface trop signature
type cover 179 euros 99 ça augmente le
prix par contre on a un produit qui va
vraiment bien en alcantara qui est
vraiment tout doux très agréable
doux au toucher une fois de plus de très
belles finitions sur ce produit très
agréable pour bosser pour travailler
microns soit continuer son savoir-faire
et dans sa lignée avec un clavier qui
est parfaitement maîtrisée en plus de ça
on a doublé ici donc une machine qui est
au top de la connectivité nos comptes
termes de performances productivité
qualité de travail en un produit qui est
très bien qui est plus destiné je dirais
pour un outil professionnels nomades
qu'on va emmener avec soi facilement on
n'est pas sur un produit qui est destiné
à faire de la vidéo oui en terme de rome
par exemple 4 8 16 16 c'est bien peu
commencé à bosser avec 16 mai 8 et 4
s'est largement pas assez on est donc
plus sur un produit pour pouvoir faire
un petit peu de photoshop
sans trop trop trop trop de cas de tous
les côtés mais ça fonctionne quand même
vraiment bien sûr un outil qui est
destiné une flotte de commerciaux qui
vont se déplacer et qui ont besoin de
toujours leurs machines de boire
bouteille facilement quel que soit
l'endroit où ils sont un produit qui est
extrêmement polyvalent mais qui va pas
pouvoir vous permettre de faire de la 3d
des choses comme ça mais qui vous offre
quand même beaucoup d' usage qui dit
professionnel 10h notamment au niveau de
son téléphone là il ya un truc qui est
vraiment cool au psy vous et moi que
j'ai un petit peu de travers ah désolé
je vais pas vous faire trancher la tête
ça va comme ça y'a un truc qui est
vraiment intéressant que microsoft a mis
en place la dessus au niveau de cette
surface pro 7
eh bien c'est la possibilité de pouvoir
lier son téléphone à sa surface
ça vous permet donc d'avoir sur votre
tablette directement et bien vos sms vos
photos de pouvoir passer des coups de
fil même directement à partir de votre
tablette accès vos notifications ce qui
fait que lorsque vous êtes en train de
bosser vous êtes dans un côté un petit
peu productivité vous êtes dans un côté
de productivité vous êtes concentré
peut-être en train de travailler et bien
vous n'avez pas de distractions externe
et ça pour moi ça va vraiment dans le
bon sens et notamment pour usage
professionnel tout ce passe dans votre
pc vous venez vous l'ouvrez vous allez
ici tout en bas votre téléphone donc là
j'ai la liste de mes appels appels
entrants appels sortants vous pouvez
venir composer cydia quand votre numéro
de téléphone
hélas si vous regardez vous avez accès à
vos photos vos messages notification vos
apps est donc l'ajax à quelques photos
récentes je peux cliquer dessus
ça m'ouvre ma photo ici qui pourtant est
dans mon smartphone ça c'est plutôt bien
donc la premier message que je cache
avec nos mains comme sa vie privée quand
tu nous tiens les dernières
notifications depuis mon smartphone je
peux tout venir paramétrer faire les
choix ce que jacques tys que des actifs
moi j'aime beaucoup ce produit microsoft
surface à chaque fois je trouve que les
produits de
la gamme surface c'est de pas tomber
sont des produits qui sont vraiment
toujours très relevés sont toujours une
sensation de robustesse microsoft garde
toujours ses acquis microsoft conserve
ce qui sait faire son savoir faire
c'est peut-être pour ça que on pourrait
effectivement que eh bien il ya un petit
peu moins de prise de risque en terme de
design tout simplement pour garder la
base le socle qui est très bon et elle
est toujours plus loin en termes de
performances donc ça c'est vraiment
chouette donc une fois de plus microsoft
nous livre un produit qui est bon qui
marche très bien qui est une belle
évolution de la surface prosys il n'y a
pas grand changement ya rien de bien
novateur il manque un peu l'effet waouh
alors après microsoft c'est aussi
l'innovation d'un point de vue purement
logicielle notamment au niveau ce que
vous allez pouvoir faire entre votre
stylet et office
moi j'aime beaucoup ce produit je trouve
vraiment très très bien très bien mise à
jour cette année surtout le fait d'avoir
rajouté cette prise usb c'est ça peut
paraître un petit peu du point de détail
mais vu toute la connectique va là
dessus vu qu'on est sur une
uniformisation au niveau de la
connectique avec de l'usb c'est ça va
dans le bon sens et ça s'est vraiment
bien maintenant il faut un peu plus de
vitesse
il faut comme vous le disait du
thunderbolt roi pour permettre d'aller
un peu plus loin connecter des disques
durs beaucoup plus rapide mais en tout
cas quoi qu'il en soit faux cette
surface est intéressante
on en reparle d'ici quelques jours sur
la surface trop disent maintenant on va
parler de la question de la douloureuse
question du prix parce que oui
effectivement
cette machine et coûte un peu d'argent
alors vous commencez avec un tarif de
base
j'arrête un jour ce genre de truc 919
euros ces tarifs d'entrée vous êtes sur
un intel core i3 blessures le début de
la config tout en sachant que pour
l'instant alors à laquelle je trouve
cette vidéo donc sera pas forcément
valable tout le temps mais tout de suite
vous trouvez à 779 euros
ça s'est vraiment bien il faut le garder
en tête moi ici j'ai une config san
intel core i5 saisi cas de ram 256 go de
stockage et ça ça coûte 1500 69 euros et
bien évidemment en ce moment on le
trouve à 1333 bienvenue à 65 centimes
pour être très précis
alors ça c'est le prix effectivement
j'irai de l'ordinateur sans ça s'ouvre
et la surface signature qu'il cover le
petit clavier ont tout simplement
eh bien ça ça coûte 179 euros 90 si vous
voulez le stylet et coûte 109 euros 99
et si vous voulez la petite souris en
plus pourquoi pas vous avez le trac pas
de l'arc qui est bien mais je peux
comprendre aussi qu'on veuille la souris
pour aller un peu plus lointain
expérientiel de travail pour sentir
beaucoup mieux
eh bien il faut rajouter 89 euros 99 ce
qui fait que si vous portez sur une
config un petit peu d'entre elles
anne aux alentours de 1000 1200 euros et
bien voyez il faut rajouter entre 300 à
presque 400 euros pour avoir le style et
le clavier et pourquoi pas la petite
souris donc ça coûte un peu plus cher
la question se pose par rapport à des
ultra portables que vous pourriez
trouver en tout cas la concurrence
est ce que cette machine est
intéressante oui ou non pour moi cette
machine elle est vraiment bien il est
vraiment faite pour vous si vous êtes un
microsoft indique ça vous paraîtra
normal si vous utilisez tous les
produits de microsoft qui passait pas
être anormal d'avoir un produit qui est
complètement optimisé pour c'est clair
c'est logique et notamment tout ce qui
va être surface mais il faut l'utiliser
une fois de plus avec le stylet et
lapointe coup vous avez un combo qui
marchent merveilleusement bien je compte
s'en vont maintenant combien ce que vous
en pensez en bas en commentaire comment
vous la trouvez cette surface procède
par rapport à la surface prosys de la
dernière est ce que vous aviez un
produit de surface pro générations
antérieures est ce que vous avez acheté
ce modèle et si oui comment vous le
trouvez et est ce que vous pourriez vous
laisser tenter
sur ce on fait des gros becs 1 on
s'embrasse entre les divisions samba
beaucoup d'amour je vous embrasse
à demain ciao